Nigel Farage the UK bleeder says the
result means Nick Clegg's position is
untenable well it's got views of the
former lib dem leader Simon Campbell
joins us live from Edinburgh and very
good to talk to you swimming now you're
known for your frankness and over the
years you've been with the Liberals and
then the lib dems you've had good
results about bad results this has got
to be what the lowest of the low well we
had a pretty bad result in 1989 when we
got six percent of the vote in the
European elections so we face difficult
times in the past but the way in which
you deal with that is the dust yourself
down pick yourself up and start all over
again and my view since you've raised
the question of Nick Clegg's leadership
is that he is the person best qualified
to take us through the next ten months
through the general election campaign
and thereafter through the next
parliament because I'm a no doubt that
it's his courage and resilience which
will be absolutely essential in this
more difficult time for us than we would
have hoped but you saw that letter
didn't you from some of the lib dem
activists yesterday the more or less
said about Nick Clegg well yes you have
done well and you've taken on the burden
of governing and you've had to take some
tough decisions but you paid the price
for that in terms of having the ear of
the electorate and to mix my metaphors
to move on to a rugby term he's carried
the ball as far as he can now it's time
to pass it on to someone else
well there were 200 people signed that
letter and of these understand some
weren't even members of the party the
total membership of the party is 44,000
so I think one has to put it into proper
context the other context I would put it
into is one which I think you'll recall
and it is this that when we entered
coalition Nick Clegg got a overwhelming
majority of the members of parliament of
the executive of the party and indeed of
the party as a whole no one ever
pretended it was going to be easy and I
understand disappointment but a time of
disappointment what you don't do
politically is to indulge in what would
be six weeks or even perhaps three
months of damaging introspection while
we chose a new leader okay well stay
with the leadership but what about the
message and the delivery of it isn't it
a dangerous thing for a political party
to do in effect and it seems the lib
dems have done which is say we won't
listen to you all the other parties all
the big parties are saying right we need
to to listen and absorb this result you
went into that campaign you carried out
that campaign saying you are wrong about
the European Union we have to stay in
now the electorate seemed to been saying
some of us have doubt some of us want to
leave we want a referendum we want to
think about it the lib dems are saying
forget all that you're wrong with
staying in but what we were saying was
we understand a reformed European Union
and a lot of countries in Europe like
Germany and Holland and others who like
us are in favor of reform but of course
if you'd want reform then the way in
which you do it in the European Union's
to build coalitions for that purpose
threatening to leave is hardly likely to
persuade people that they should ally
themselves with proposals which you may
simply never be around to try and
implement and that's why I think it's
perfectly sensible for us to say look
Europe needs reform that's a different
institution from what it was and but it
was there were only six members started
all those years ago and they meet it
aftermath of the sec
World War but the essential values and
the essential opportunities of the EU
still remain can I just put one perhaps
slightly wider point two units this we
are obviously inclined to look about all
this domestically and then we look at it
in terms of Europe itself but there's
one capital in the world which would
look upon dismemberment or even dilution
of the European Union's a great deal of
favor and that's Moscow as evidenced by
some of the behavior of mr. Putin in
recent weeks so we have to remember that
what we do domestically here in the
United Kingdom of what we do within the
European Union can have implications
well beyond the boundaries of both are
always fascinating to talk to you thanks
very much making at that point there
some in campbell there live in the
scottish capital edinburgh